RACHEL ROSSIN:
Almost my entire life
is lived virtually on a screen.
And what I'm
looking for is a way
to bring the digital experience
put into physical form.
I grew up in a place where,
like, escapism was necessary.
I was drawing, and painting,
and programming, and building
computers since I was eight.
It's a fascination
with, like, wanting
to create, like, weird
worlds in a virtual space.
[ambient music]
Well, first, I'm
sketching, and painting,
and modeling in 3D software
and video game engines.
What I'm doing is
I'm just giving
it logic so it has randomness.
I'm just giving it
randomness that mimics life.
There's this obsession with
most artists with the idea
of exploding the
fourth dimension, where
the physical and
impermanent meet.
That space, like, the
in-between is what I'm trying
to do almost in every show.
I'm trying to find the
link between the thing that
feels impossible and the
thing that's tangible.
I can use parts of sculpture
to inform virtual reality
and, you know, vise versa.
The most beautiful and fragile
parts of my human experience
are stored in screens.
Being interested in
that and-- and being
in love with that as well,
it's a complicated feeling.
I mean, I certainly am feeling
like I'm losing my physicality,
the loss of translation between,
like, the body and mind,
the digital and the physical.
And the response
to that, I think,
was these pieces that were
really physical that really
is sort of like false bodies.
I was creating these small
sculptures in virtual reality,
and then printed
onto plexiglass,
and then formed with my
body with a blowtorch,
creating, like, an
artificial armor of a screen.
What we're looking
for in technology
is to enhance being
a human being.
As virtuality gets better,
our relationship with reality
also becomes richer.
The hope is that virtuality
sort of stays bad,
because you don't want it to
become any sort of substitute
for reality.
But then as a-- like,
a counter to that,
it can also become, like, such
an incredible tool for healing,
and for more truthful
experiences, and for change,
you know?
Really, for-- like, for change.